est avec nous pour une édition spéciale
de vue de Russie bonsoir Elena depuis
presque un an vous analysez dans cette
chronique hebdomadaire la propagande du
président russe Vladimir Poutine sur
fond bien sûr de Guérande Ukraine mais
avant cela vous avez été correspondante
en Russie pendant 10 ans notre chef de
bureau à Moscou vous avez quitté la
Russie peu après c'est invasion à grande
échelle et juste avant et bien vous êtes
rendu à la frontière ukrainienne côté
russe pour faire des reportages pour
France 24 sur cette concentration des
troupes russes sans précédent qui avait
fait peser depuis des mois à la crainte
d'une invasion oui je suis effectivement
partie tournée ces images regardez les
troupes russes étaient alors stationnés
dans les champs des régions de Rostov et
Belgorod côté rue ça va frontière avec
l'Ukraine depuis l'automne elles se sont
ensuite mis en mouvement pour envahir
l'Ukraine j'ai vu alors pour la première
fois ces tank frappé de la lettre Z
devenu le symbole de cette de cette
invasion russe à grande échelle et
c'était
identifiant avoir à ce moment là parce
qu'on ne comprenait absolument pas la
signification de cette lettre apparue
sur cet angle d'ailleurs Vladimir
Poutine ne s'en est jamais expliqué
depuis ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'à
ce moment là vu de Russie depuis des
semaines on moquait on raillé vertement
les inquiétudes américaines et
occidentales sur une possible invasion
russe une attaque russe écoutée par
exemple ce que disait le 16 février soit
8 jours avant cette attaque la
porte-parole officielle du ministère
russe des Affaires étrangères Maria
zafalova au cours de son briefing
hebdomadaire pour les journalistes
pendant une trentaine de minutes elle
fustige les médias occidentaux pour je
cite leur hystérie leur désinformation
et leur propagande d'écouter
nous sommes devenus les témoins d'une
nouvelle phase de la campagne de
désinformation occidentale sur une
invasion russe rivée en Ukraine où notre
prétendu agression
tout ce que nous lisons dans les médias
occidentaux à ce sujet c'est de la
désinformation
il n'y aura aucune guerre personne n'a
personne INHA l'intention d'attaquer qui
que ce soit alors elle tient ses propos
alors que tous les voyants sont au rouge
oui au même moment les États-Unis
estiment à 150 000 nombres de soldats
russes massés à la frontière avec
l'Ukraine mais en Russie les médias
officiels russes ne montrent absolument
pas cette concentration de troupes non
la propagande russe elle prépare
l'opinion russe à la guerre autrement
elle inverse comme toujours le récit à
longueur de journée les chaînes de
télévision russe Martel que l'OTAN
inondent l'Ukraine d'armes et se
rapproche des frontières de la Russie à
ce moment-là face à la menace de
l'invasion russe les Américains les
Britanniques les Allemands en sont à
livrer des armes antichard des armes de
défense antérienne des casques même donc
des armes défensives mais écoutez ce
qu'on dit la télévision russe nous
sommes à J-2 semaines de cette invasion
à grande échelle le 11 février 2022
la situation est de nouveau dans
l'impasse à cause de Kiev qui refuse de
dialoguer avec le dombasque il Occident
ne veut pas de la paix dans cette région
les États-Unis et l'OTAN utilisent la
situation à l'est de l'Ukraine comme
prétexte pour accroître leur présence
militaire aux frontières de la Russie
donc là à ce moment là selon la
télévision russe ce n'est pas la Russie
qui menace l'Ukraine par sa présence
militaire aux frontières mais le temps
qui menace la Russie par sa présence
militaire en
Ukraine comment cette réalité parallèle
elle est perçue par les Russes le
message est reçu 5 sur 5 l'air se pose
de télévision que vous venez de voir
dans cet extrait je l'ai tourné à Moscou
chez Oleg un prof de fitness mon but
alors en tant que correspondant en
Russie c'était d'aller recueillir la
parole des Russes lambda face à ses
inquiétudes occidentales de guerre
imminente écoutez la conversation que
nous avons eu à ce moment-là avec mes
collègues
concentre ses troupes à la frontière
avec l'Ukraine
nous n'avons personne à la frontière
ah ben si vous avez bien vu toutes ces
images
les images ça ne veut rien dire il y a
des camps militaires entiers là-bas en
ce moment
peut-être ça je n'en sais rien on nous
le montre pas mais c'est le territoire
de la Russie c'est mon pays qui fait ce
que je veux nous n'avons pas traversé la
frontière mis en veille un bout de
territoire ils se sont approchés trop
près des frontières russes c'est le pays
voisin quand même mais ce n'est même
plus le territoire ukrainien l'OTAN il
commande comme elle veut
et ce alors même qu'aujourd'hui
l'Ukraine va l'OTAN n'a toujours pas
accepté d'intégrer l'Ukraine mais Oleg
lui il n'est pas au courant du fait que
la Russie a mal ses troupes à la
frontière et combien même elle le ferait
c'est pour se défendre de l'Ukraine et
de l'OTAN aussi exactement et noter
qu'il dit que la Russie n'a rien à se
reprocher puisqu'elle n'a pas envahi
l'Ukraine c'est faux l'Ukraine a déjà
envahi pardon la Russie a déjà envahi la
Crimée et la région ukrainienne du
Dombas à l'Est dès 2014 mais Vladimir
Poutine l'a toujours démenti et olegs le
croit parce qu'il est travaillé depuis
des années par cette propagande russe de
haine et de négation de l'État et de la
nation ukrainienne écoutait ce collègue
me disait encore
ils ont toujours trahi tout le monde
eux-mêmes le village voisin le pays
voisin ils ont la traîtrise dans le sang
comme la vie moi je les aurais envahi
depuis longtemps parce que c'est
humaniste depuis longtemps parce que ce
territoire ce n'est pas celui de
l'Ukraine la Crimée n'est pas le
territoire de l'Ukraine et ne l'a jamais
été historiquement
et ce n'est pas seulement ce que pensent
les Russes et les NA mais aussi les
habitants des régions de doniak et
louansk
occupé depuis 2014 par la Russie non et
c'est le plus terrible selon moi dans
cette guerre que je couvre depuis 2014
c'est le fait que ces populations de ces
territoires elle ne voit pas les Russes
comme les responsables de la guerre
comme les responsables de leur malheur
mais comme des libérateurs qui viennent
les sauver des nazis alors on fait un
bref point quand même sur la situation
pour la dénouer vous voyez vous allez
voir cette carte avec l'Ukraine la
péninsule de Crimée annexée par la
Russie en 2014 en réponse à une
révolution pro-européenne à Kiev et
voyez aussi en rouge donc ces régions de
Donetsk et Laurence partiellement
envahie par Moscou au même moment à ce
moment-là des républiques séparatistes
ils sont proclamés la propagande russe
Martel que ces entités naissent d'une
rébellion locale face à ces nazis qui
aurait pris le pouvoir acquieff à la
faveur de cette révolution mais pour ne
pas céder le don-basse aux Russes comme
à la cédé la Crimée l'Ukraine elle
envoie ses troupes sans suit une guerre
d'artillerie ou la Russie fournit côté
dit prorus de l'armement et on voit même
son armée régulière menait certaines
opérations mais pendant 8 ans Vladimir
Poutine ni tout implication dans ce
conflit il prétend que c'est une guerre
civile en Ukraine les populations du
côté envahies par la Russie elles
adèrent pleinement à ce mythe du fait
d'abord du caleçon quels sont
prédisposés par leurs liens historiques
avec la Russie mais aussi du fait de
cette propagande qui se déverse sur elle
durant durant des années et le 18
février 2022 cette propagande elle est
en train de préparer l'invasion en
général de l'Ukraine pour cela elle met
en scène le scénario d'une prétendue
attaque imminente de l'Ukraine de grande
ampleur contre cette région du don-basse
parmi les éléments de scénographie on
l'a un peu oublié mais les autorités des
républiques séparatistes locales
déclenche les sirènes d'alerte au
bombardement aérien à doniak capitale
d’une de ces et allogances capitale de
ces entités séparatistes écoutées
[Musique]
ces sirène d'alerte est dans la foulée
et bien les autorités de ses entités
séparatistes évacue femme enfants et
personnes âgées vers la Russie oui ce
qu'on comprendra ensuite c'est que ces
évacuations et bien elles avaient pour
but de séparer les familles pour pouvoir
mobiliser les hommes pour qu'ils aillent
combattre mais à ce moment-là les 19 20
21 février tout ceci est présenté par la
Russie comme une opération de sauvetage
de masse de ces populations civiles face
à cette prétendue menace ukrainienne
c'est à ce moment là donc que je me suis
rendue dans la région dans le sud dans
la région de Rostov à la rencontre de
ces réfugiés écoutez à quel point ils
étaient convaincus de cette réalité
parallèle dans laquelle ils avaient
plongé la Russie depuis 8 ans
[Musique]
alors on sent beaucoup d'agressivité ces
personnes alors que vous ne faites que
poser des questions légitimes comment
fait-on quand on est journaliste pour
travailler dans ce contexte si
particulier ça doit être dur parfois et
vous y avez passé 10 ans oui alors cette
agressivité chez les proposines dès lors
qu'on relève simplement ce qui est de
l'ordre de la réalité et les constantes
dès lors que cela peut nuire à l'image
de la Russie ou Vladimir Poutine parce
que cette propagande justement elle ne
joue pas sur la rationalité mais
beaucoup sur l'affect sur ce sentiment
d'amour envers son leader et le
sentiment de haine envers l'ennemi qui
est l'Occident donc en fait c'est
purement une propagande totalitaire
alors parfois on est dans cette réalité
parallèle ou tout le monde dit noir
alors que vous savez que c'est blanc il
faut prendre un petit peu de recul
parfois on peut aussi en rire comme
cette fois lorsque le FSB est allé trop
loin dans ses mises en scène pour mettre
en scène une prétendue attaque de
l'Ukraine ou de l'OTAN contre la Russie
le 21 février les journaux télévisés
russes de plus en plus alarmiste il
passe en édition spéciale regardez
l'ouverture du JT de Rossi à 1 c'est
l'une des deux deux principales chaînes
du pays
[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre édition spéciale
sur la chaîne Rossia 1 je suis Ernest
matsitus bonjour Aujourd'hui la division
militaire de District Sud et les gardes
frontières ont empêché une violation de
notre frontière dans la région de Rostov
tôt le matin ils ont arrêté là-bas un
groupe de reconnaissance et de sabotage
ukrainien
entièrement détruit l'un des postes des
gardes frontières le FSB précise que ce
poste se trouvait à 150 mètres de la
frontière avec l'Ukraine le tir n'a pas
fait de blesser les démineurs
travaillent sur place
très alarmiste mais ce qu'on voit à
l'image ne ressemble pas vraiment à un
poste frontière oui ces images elles ont
été relayées dans un chat telegram de
journalistes dont je faisais partie par
les autorités de cette région de Rostov
pour les journalistes qui étaient venus
couvrir cette fameuse crise soi-disant
des réfugiés regarder la réaction de ces
journalistes pourtant ils font eux aussi
la propagande du Kremlin il y en a un
qui dit il est joli ce poste frontière
ça ressemble plus à un hangar dit un
autre vous pouvez nous dire c'est quoi
ce post frontière essaye un troisième et
ce à quoi le responsable presse
finalement répond toutes les questions
sont à adressées aux fessb de Russie
donc voyez parfois même les
propagandistes du Kremlin ne sont pas
dues et pourtant l'heure est grave
puisque vos sources à ce moment-là vous
ont prévenu d'une guerre imminente oui
mais source parmi les paramilitaires que
l'on s'est extrêmement actif dans cette
guerre n'est ce pas aux côtés du Kremlin
et de la du ministère russe de la
Défense et parmi eux un certain
Alexandre borodaï c'est un russe il a
participé à former l'entité séparatiste
de Transnistrie en Moldavie la remonte à
1991 vous voyez des technologies qui
sont rodées de longue date par la Russie
au début de la guerre en Ukraine en 2014
il devient le premier Premier ministre
de cette entité séparatiste dite prorus
de Donetsk puis Moscou le Démé au profit
d'un local vous le voulez ensemble sur
ces images Alexandre zarachenko parce
que un Russe a un poste aussi élevé en
DNR et bien c'était trop visible la
Russie n'y est pas officiellement on le
rappelle et depuis Alexandre boroda il
dirige cette organisation qui se
présente officiellement comme une
organisation de vétérans bénévole ayant
combattu côté russe dans le Dombasle
voilà les images de leur locaux que j'ai
filmé à Moscou en réalité les
commandants de cette organisation boroda
et en tête ce sont des mercenaires ils
sont payés par l'État russe à ce moment
là alors du tournage de ces images je
crois que c'était le 16 février
Alexandre boroda il me dit texto une
grande guerre est inévitable je lui
demande quand il me dit d'ici au moins
trois semaines je lui demande pourquoi
voici ce qu'il me répond
climatique il faut que les sols sèchent
et en ce moment
les chenilles des temps qu'en mouvement
sans liseré là-bas et vous pensez bien
que pas même ces idiots de militaires
Ukrainiens ne mèneraient la haut par la
route parce que les routes sont à vues
et apporter de l'artillerie évidemment
leur troupes ne pourront même pas entrer
en combat si elles avancent par les
routes
ça c'est seul boueux dû à la fonte des
neiges cette période de l'année que les
experts militaires ont par la suite dit
être en grande partie responsable de la
débâcle de l'armée russe oui en fait ce
que décrit Alexandre borodaï c'est par
exemple cette débâcle de la colonne de
temps que russe avançant sur Kiev par
une route il est évidemment chargé de
véhiculer le discours officiel russe
donc il ne peut absolument pas face
caméra me dire que c'est la Russie qui
va attaquer il me dit donc que même ses
imbéciles d'ukrainien ne seront pas
assez idiots pour lancer une attaque
imminente par la route alors qu'il y a
la Raspoutine ça seulement en voilà
Vladimir Poutine lance l'attaque une
semaine plus tard et c'est interview ce
bout de sonore est bien c'est la preuve
que même ces généraux même les
paramilitaires même ceux qui étaient là
pour l'effort de guerre trouve que
c'était une très très mauvaise décision
d'attaquer à ce moment là et par la
suite et bien on a vu ce que ça en a
coûté à la Russie merci beaucoup